[Musique]
si vous avez un iphone ou un ordinateur
à pau ça vous a peut être déjà coûté une
petite fortune pour les faire réparer
dans une boutique apple
mais si vous allez ailleurs ça se
complique escape au fait tout pour que
vous soyez captifs allant même jusqu à
ralentir délibérément les appareils pour
que vous soyez tenté d'en acheter un
neuf
c'est ce que vous allez découvrir dans
cette fascinante en quête de nos
collègues de la sib ici
[Applaudissements]
voici l'image qui a projeté des
boutiques ou les foules de clients se
précipitent pour acheter ses produits
mais dernièrement de plus en plus de
clients se plaignent des réparations
beaucoup trop coûteuse dans les
boutiques à paul
[Applaudissements]
muni d'une caméra cachée nous voulions
vérifier si les clients d'apple se font
souvent dire que leur ordinateur brisé
ne valent pas la peine d'être réparée
même si de simples réparations peuvent
résoudre le problème
nos collègues de la civis y ont choisi
cette boutique à pau à toronto pour
régler un problème assez courant l'écran
de ce macbook ne fonctionne plus
tu les as et remporté par c
énormément de monde
[Musique]
d
plusieurs clients nous ont dit avoir
vécu des expériences semblables avec à
pau nous avons donc décidé de contre
vérifier le diagnostic sur la 1re avenue
à manhattan se trouve une petite
boutique de réparation informatique qui
appartient à louis roy semaine encore
aux études il avait commencé à réparer
des ordinateurs
aujourd'hui il partage ses connaissances
sur youtube en général apple veut que
vous étiez un nouvel appareil pour lui
de faire réparer votre appareil actuelle
ces vidéos sont souvent visionnée par
des millions de personnes
nous lui amenant le macbook qui ne
valait pas la peine d'être réparée selon
ce qu'on nous a dit à la boutique à pau
de toronto voyons voir s'ils ont raison
vous pouvez voir le logo de la pomme
regardez je crois une lampe et je la
mets derrière vous allez voir tout ce
qu'il ya sur l'écran et vous pouvez voir
le curseur et suivre son mouvement en
gros l'écran fonctionne c'est le rétro
éclairage qui ne fonctionne pas quel
écran communique avec l'ordinateur
vous voyez cette broche tordu c'est
probablement la broche qui alimente le
rétroéclairage donc avec cette petite
pince je vais ramener la broche dans la
bonne direction pour qu'elle puisse
rentrer dans sa place et quand je vais
rebrancher ça devrait fonctionner on
nous a dit de l'eau s'est infiltrée que
certains indicateurs d'humidité sont
rouges
c'est pour ça qu'ils ont cette idée là
mais ils ne deviennent pas rouge qu'en
présence d'eau ils deviennent aussi
rouge qu'il ya de l'humidité ce qui fait
en sorte que si l'ordinateur est dans un
endroit très humide tous les censeurs
deviennent rouges
même si aucun liquide ne pénètre
l'appareil on va tous rebrancher et
espérer le meilleur
et voilà la pomme apparaît et l'écran
s'allume et ça vous a pris une minute et
demie environ
si tout ce que la personne voulait que
je fasse et de remettre la broche
ça nous coûterait rien dans 99% des cas
redresser la broche permet à
l'ordinateur de fonctionner jusqu'à la
fin de sa vie
nous demandons à à pau de réagir à notre
enquête en caméra cachée dans sa
boutique de toronto
ce drapeau a refusé d'accorder une
entrevue mais nous a transmis une
déclaration soutenant que seuls ces
experts qualifiés utilisant des
composantes d'origine peuvent bien
servir les clients à paul a nié qu'elle
surfacturé ses réparations de façon
systématique
est-ce que les gens viennent souvent
vous voir après qu'apple aurait dit
qu'une réparation était possible ou trop
chères entretien à 30 fois par jour
sérieux
française
un mouvement planétaire contre les
pratiques commerciales d'apo a vu le
jour et c'est en france qu'on retrouve
plusieurs militants à paris cette
manifestation s'inspire de star wars
pour dépeindre à pau comme l' empire du
mal
ils accusent la compagnie de programmes
et l'obsolescence et d'évasion fiscale
systématique
le parlement européen veut légiférer
pour obliger à boé d'autres entreprises
à produire des appareils plus facile à
réparer
pascal durand et député au parlement
européen
apple pour moi c'est un côté un peu
finalement dinosaures mais un dinosaure
qui fait des superbes présentations avec
du powerpoint
la réalité c'est que ils peuvent être
très très conservateur et très en fait
proche des logiques de pur profit
je ne sais pas si je pourrai le faire ce
qui fait partie de ce mouvement mondial
ce sont les rippeurs café café
réparation comme ici à paris
un atelier où on remet en état des
ordinateurs ou des téléphones
gratuitement bien évidemment le
consultant ne vend pas les pièces
détachées de ses téléphones
on voit très bien qu'il ya eu une
démarche qui est une démarche volontaire
de la part des entreprises de faire en
sorte que les appareils ne dure pas
longtemps pour qu'il soit remplacé
établie en californie
ifixit et sans doute l'entreprise de
réparation indépendante la plus prospère
du continent le dirigeant d'al fixe et
est aussi devenu l'un des plus
importants porte parole aux états unis
du mouvement wright ou reaper où le
droit de réparer le droit de réparer
soutient qu'on devrait pouvoir réparer
soi-même ses objets voulait faire
réparer dans une boutique locale
auparavant ferait par un appareil qu'on
achetait aller de soi mais avec le temps
que ce soit pour une télé un aspirateur
ou un ordinateur
nous n'avons plus le choix apple veut le
plein contrôle de ses appareils du
moment où le client les achètent jusqu'à
la fin de vie du produit
et voici ce que ferait à pau pour
empêcher les réparations les plus
simples voici la vie se mettent à loeb
elle referme le dessous du macbook pro
sa tête est formé de cinq petits ronds
aucune vis courante n'est faite ainsi en
fait apple a inventé une vie saine même
uniquement pour que les gens ordinaires
et plus de difficultés à ouvrir leurs
appareils avec des outils courants à pau
a aussi décidé de colis c'est pile selon
elle fonde vite zappé les coller au
boîtier c'est dommage et inutile jamais
on avait collé de piles auparavant voici
le bouton principal le bouton principal
de certains iphone doit être remplacé
quand la fenêtre des crampes craque
j'enlève le bouton principal une
réparation simple et peu coûteuse
jusqu'à ce capot configure le système
d'exploitation pour que le téléphone
arrête de fonctionner dès qu'un bouton
principal non autorisée était détectée
c'est comme si vous changez les plus de
votre tesla tout à coup tesla détecte
que vos pneus ne lui plaisent pas
reprogramme votre auto est votre voiture
arrête de fonctionner louis grasmann et
ifixit reçoivent souvent des menaces de
poursuites s'ils publient des schémas ou
des éléments de manuels de réparation ou
encore quand ils importent des pièces de
rechange à l'achat d'un produit on
devrait nous fournir un manuel de
réparation mais en fait apple écrit le
manuel et possède les droits d'auteur
dès qu'on lui met en ligne on reçoit des
menaces
poursuites sont ne retire pas l'amendé
peut s'élever à 150 mille dollars par
publication ces menaces judiciaires ont
vraiment nu au partage en ligne des
informations
cette année aux états unis
dix-sept états ont déjà proposé de
légiférer pour obliger à paul et
d'autres compagnies à fournir à des
entreprises de réparation indépendante
des manuels de réparations et des pièces
de rechange
ça va devenir très intéressant
dès qu'on est avalée différé le barrage
va se rompre
par exemple si l'ontario vote une loi en
faveur du droit de réparer ce droit pour
être acceptée dans le monde entier
les fabricants m simplifier leurs
opérations donc ils produiront de la
même façon pour tous les marchés après
la pause
l'entreprise doit maintenant se défendre
d'avoir instauré une obsolescence
programmée qui pousse ses clients à
acheter du nouveau téléphone
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un soir de décembre 2017 dans les
bureaux de son entreprise
john paul tente de résoudre un mystère
il a des millions de clients de son
logiciel geekbench qui sert à analyser
le rendement des téléphones et des
ordinateurs
plusieurs clients constatent une forte
baisse de la vitesse de leur iphone ils
veulent en connaître la cause
ma femme a alors dit que son iphone 6
semblait plus lents et les données de
l'analyse était bien inférieure à mes
attentes pour un tel appareil un point
tel que je ne pouvais pas croire ce qui
se passait c'est alors qu'il tombe sur
une recommandation anonyme sur internet
si votre iphone élan changer la pile
mode c'était un moment heureux car ça
m'a poussé à analyser en profondeur nos
bases de données pour comprendre ce qui
se passait john paul compile les données
de rendement 2 millions d'iphone
plusieurs d'entre eux avaient ralenti à
la suite de la dernière mise à jour par
rappo de son système d'exploitation
il publie sa découverte qui démontre
scientifiquement que la direction
d'apple aurait décidé de ralentir les
iphone de ses clients sans les avertir
à sa grande surprise la compagnie
confirme rapidement les faits tout en
soulignant qu'elle ne faisait rien de
mal à paul a récemment reconnu qu'elle
avait secrètement ralenti le rendement
de certains fans
les a vus d'apo qui admet ralentir
sciemment d'anciens modèles d'iphone
font la manchette par tout le monde
cela ressemble à de l'obsolescence
programmée pour pousser les
consommateurs à acheter inutilement un
nouveau produit ce que tim coq le
président d'ap omni
et
la france vient de voter une loi qui
fait en sorte que l'obsolescence
programmée est un crime
ap ont fait l'objet d'une enquête
formelle suite à la plainte déposée par
l'association hope halte à
l'obsolescence programmée
donc aujourd'hui c'est passible de deux
ans d'emprisonnement 300000 euros
d'amendé et jusqu'à 5% du chiffre
d'affaires d'une entreprise est ce que
le ou les problèmes de votre iphone sont
réellement apparu après une mise à jour
de l'ios 96%
oui l'avocat de up et meunier appuie sa
plainte sur une enquête auprès de
milliers de clients français d'abord il
collabore avec les enquêteurs du
gouvernement
la plante et repose sur plusieurs
éléments et plus de 8000 témoignages de
personnes qui ont constaté effectivement
des détériorations dans leur iphone à la
suite de cette mise à jour et nous on a
apporté ces éléments la justice et c'est
la justice à la suite de ça qui a ouvert
une enquête
l'avocate canadienne en droit des
consommateurs shana scarlett travail en
californie elle a participé à une
poursuite contre à pau qui a dû payer
405 millions de dollars après avoir
enfin les lois antitrust américaines
l'avocate mène en ce moment un recours
collectif contre apport si apple avait
vraiment eu à coeur les intérêts des
consommateurs
la compagnie aurait pu leur dire qu'un
simple changement de la pile aurait
entièrement réglé le problème
ça aurait évité un ralentissement des
fermeture subite ou d'avoir à acheter un
nouveau téléphone pour ce reportage à
port a refusé nous accorder une entrevue
mais en mars dernier un comité
parlementaire du gouvernement canadien a
cherché à obtenir des réponses
et l'avocate d'apo au canada s'y
présenter son unique objectif de cette
mise à jour logicielle était que les
clients puissent utiliser dans ses
modèles d'iphone aux batteries
vieillissante sans arrêt subit et non de
les pousser à acheter de nouveaux
modèles
je ne crois pas qu après les commis de
faute mais la raison de votre présence
aujourd'hui la non divulgation de ce
ralentissement est ce qu'elle était
intentionnelle ou non intentionnelle non
intentionnelle une réponse qui ne
satisfait pas les détracteurs d'apple
ont des vents la logique de duché pas de
l'enfant qu'ils aient pris les doigts
dans la confiture et qui dit non mais
c'est parce que j'avais vu que le
bouchon était mal vissé et donc c'est ma
main qui a glissé mais j'allais remettre
le bouchon
moi j'ai l'espoir que apple dans dix
quinze vingt ans si elle veut continuer
à être le leader des téléphones
portables et des ordinateurs va devoir
changer de système
et va devoir proposer des ordinateurs
des téléphones des tablettes qui dure
qui sont réparables
[Musique]
au nom de toute l'équipe on espère que
vous avez apprécié les enquêtes de ce
soir on se retrouve la semaine prochaine
pour une autre enquête
[Musique]